hi my name is mason gooding i play
andrew on love victor
and today i'm going to be reading your
thirst tweets
i'm so glad my my grandmother is not on
twitter
she would be throwing a fit
[Music]
okay so i watched booksmart and i loved
it
and thought nick was really hot so i
googled his age before tweeting this and
omg he is cuba getting junior's son
i know you wouldn't believe it he's so
pretty and i'm so mean in a thirst tweet
you're also mentioning my father
so while i talk about being thirsty
to think about my dad thank you for that
lesbians for mason gooding mason getting
for lesbians
okay that's that's first and foremost
i'm not saying i would let mason good
and break my back like a glow stick but
that's exactly what i'm saying and i'm
i'm
i'm i'm saying i know my way around a
glow sticker too i don't know why
but whenever i see mason gooding the
title track of
a m tn wait hold on what's am goes off
in my head
it's called you want to be on top i do
know that oh
that's so sweet they think of that
whenever they hear me that's so cute
oh oh oh oh
they want me on top
i guess play where you feel comfortable
right mason goodings
yeah you are and book smart always gets
me i die each time
yeah you are watching love victor mason
gooding
step on me now get up off the floor
nobody's stepping on you you're worth
more than that okay
step on me they say well depends on what
you're into hey guys
i'm sure some of you have seen my tweets
and i just wanted to say that i decided
to deactivate and leave this account out
for good
i have loved every interaction i've made
but i won't have time to tweet anymore
now that i'm marrying mason gooding
when's the wedding i'm thinking kawaii
and
i think it'll be officiated by a bunch
of golden retriever puppies
mason gooding saying he cried watching
to all the boys
yeah i love one man i cried twice in
that movie actually and i've seen it
six times so i don't think i cried twice
every time
but i'm probably getting up there to to
to
pen tuple uh cries can you guys delete
all mason getting pictures from your
camera roll and send them to me instead
there's no reason for my boyfriend to be
in other people's camera rolls i should
be the only one who gets to look at him
on a daily basis
he is my boyfriend nachos that's right
you protect your claim you take it
and you don't let nobody say nothing
about it okay and part of me is like i
don't i don't deserve such
kind words and then the other part of me
is like i just appreciate the centering
there's no reason for mason getting to
be that good looking
he's gorgeous oh and his personality is
golden
and his acting is so great that might
just be one of the sweeter things
anyone's ever said to me
we came a long way from being bullied in
the locker rooms okay
no i will not have sex with you i'm
saving my pure
virgin flesh pocket for mason gooding
what a thoughtful thing to do i
appreciate that but that's okay have
experiences
uh figure out your sexuality and who you
are there's no harm in it we're happy to
wait
nick from book smart how do you like
your eggs cooked in the morning please
call me
sunny side up always mason gooding from
book smart
please come mess up this coochie i i
could be so lucky
i'm honored what an anointing me
i hate men vomiting emoji also me
mason getting hard face you know it's
funny heartface is what i what i
think whenever i think of you so that's
that's fitting mason gooding
please flood my intestines i have a few
biology questions about
the uh the inner workings of that
statement but you know what
appreciate your saying sorry if this is
too straightforward
but i am mason gooding's [ __ ] and i
live to serve him and send him
i guess the correct term for [ __ ] is
female dog and i love dogs
so i'd love to raise a dog with someone
i appreciate you i appreciate your
sentiments
and uh if anything i'm grateful that you
take the time to let me know how you're
feeling
your opinions your feelings they matter
and if nothing else they matter to me
oh my goodness gracious i am taking my
mom off of twitter
the second